a las 9:31 minutos de la mañana
desapareció Entre el cielo encapotado
del desierto del gobi la nave sensei su
destino es la estación espacial tiangong
400 kilómetros más allá los tres
tripulantes son el primer relevo Desde
que la estación quedó concluida en
noviembre pasado y ahí coincidirán
durante unos días con sus colegas que
regresarán pronto a casa tras seis meses
en el espacio lo más noticioso de la
misión es que un civil rompe por primera
vez el monopolio del ejército de
liberación Popular en el gremio de
tyconautas o astronautas chinos se trata
de un profesor de ingeniería
aeroespacial de la más prestigiosa
Universidad de Pekín y que supervisará
la mayoría de los experimentos
científicos la estación espacial es la
Joya de la corona del programa espacial
chino y nace en un despecho ocurrió
cuando Estados Unidos vetó a China de la
estación espacial internacional alegando
sus recelos a compartir tecnologías
sensible los chinos se sintieron
humillados señalados como ladrones y
Poco después anunciaron que construirían
la suya en abril de 2021 empezaron las
misiones y apenas un año y medio después
fue completada la culminación de la
venganza china llegará cuando Estados
Unidos jubile la ya achacosa estación
espacial internacional y la china sea la
única en funcionamiento el año que viene
Además está previsto que sea acoplado un
telescopio con un campo de visión 350
veces mayor que del hubble que entró en
funcionamiento hace más de 30 años